This website is completely HTML. It's
scoring 95 plus on Google PageSpeed
Insights. It is SEO and GEO optimized
out of the box with schema markup
injected into every single page to
ensure that the pages index, rank, and
also get cited by AI. And I built this
website in about 5 minutes using this
new AI builder. And I'll show you guys
exactly how you can do the same. Now,
being an SEO, it's often that we have to
create different websites for different
clients or ourselves, but it takes a lot
of time to actually create the website,
make it HTML, and actually make sure
that it's following best practices for
SEO and GEO, and do that at scale,
especially when you need to create
multiple pages at a time. And that's why
we actually created this tool. Now, it's
an early early beta. If you want to get
access, just comment HTML below, and
I'll give you guys a free beta access.
But, the way that it works is you first
start by setting up your website with
your business name and your business
details. So, we want to first start by
entering the inputs of the business
name, business type.
It can be local niche, professional
service. Right now, the template works
the best for local websites, but you can
use it for any other template.
And then we're again we're just going to
fill out these inputs here. So, city
we're going to go with Toronto, and then
for country we're going to go with
Canada.
So, next we need to enter in our
OpenRouter API key. This is what's going
to be used in order for us to write out
these pages because we will be writing a
lot of pages, and we want to make sure
that we're using our own API key so we
can control the cost. If you want to
generate images, it also supports that.
You can use your fall AI API key to
generate images. And then choose
whichever model you like to use. We're
going to go to continue, and then we're
going to see the pages or the site
structure of this site. So, we see that
we have the home, about us, services,
blog, contact, FAQ, and our location
pages. Our location pages will be the
service that you provide plus different
locations that you're targeting to help
you rank for those specific areas. And
because this is using AI, we can do this
at scale.
So, you can really target a lot of those
um areas within your niche, and all of
the content will be unique as you will
see soon. So, I'm just going to put in a
couple of cities here in Toronto. And
then for
services, I'm going to copy over some of
these services here.
And we're going to paste it in here. So,
now we have our services and then we
have our location pages. Now, we're good
to go. We go to complete and right away
we have our website. And we can see here
we have our site site structure that we
can take a look at. Now, when you're
first going into this, nothing is going
to be published. I've already went ahead
and done this, so that's why it's
published. But, off the bat, we can see
that we have our service pages here,
which has the services that we entered.
And if you scroll down, we also have our
location pages. So, if we're doing
garage doors as a service, we have
garage door in Toronto. We have garage
door in Oakville, garage door in Ajax.
Whatever areas we put in will also be
reflected in our locations. So, right
off the bat, we already have 51 pages in
which we can create. We can actually
create all these pages at once. For now,
I wouldn't recommend it cuz you're still
working out some kinks within the
software.
But, as you can see, everything is
already set up for you and you don't
have to do the heavy lifting. And right
off the bat, everything is going to be
SEO and GEO ready on the site. So, you
don't have to do anything additional.
Your robots.txt file is going to be
configured. llms.txt
is also going to be configured. JSON
endpoint sitemap um llm um is also going
to be configured. So, there are some
other things that you need to configure
on yourself manually, but out of the
box, you're going to have a good uh GEO
uh um a good GEO sort of starting ground
and also a good GEO SEO starting ground
as well. And as you can see, there's
going to be full audits that's It's to
be baked in along with keyword research
to allow you to know what you need to
create uh for your website without doing
any heavy lifting yourself. So,
essentially, you'll be able to do
everything within this one platform. So,
now if I go over to my service pages
here, I can take a look at any one of
them. I can create it with AI just by
clicking that button.
Uh I've already went ahead and done a
couple of these pages. So, let's go
ahead and take a look at what the pages
actually look like. So, you have service
pages and we also have location pages.
Now, this is a service page, I believe.
It's telling us to update our site
profile so that the AI can use more
relevant information. Right? So, I'll
show you how to do that in just 1
second. But, right off the bat, we can
see our SEO meta title,
garage installation with our company,
with our meta description, with our
contact information, and our custom
information that we filled out in our
site identity.
We have to work on our OG title and
description and image.
But, if we scroll down here, we can see
our JSON
um has been injected into this page.
Right? So, we can actually go ahead and
test this in Google to make sure that
our JSON has properly been indexed or
has properly been created for Google.
So, really, really powerful stuff here.
Uh we're going to click publish. It's
already published. So, I'll show you
what it actually looks like on the
website. And here are some of our other
pages as well. Let's take a look at our
location page. Again, it's telling us
what's missing, but we can see the
content here.
We can see the JSON, uh the schema has
been added in. We can also add FAQs and
those were all will automatically be
added in as well, including your
featured image once you turn that on.
So, let's go ahead and publish site.
Just keep in mind that your site is
going to be published on Netlify for
now. Keep in mind your site will be
published on Netlify for now, but
eventually, as we roll it out, you will
be able to um publish it on your own
custom domain. This is a dark version or
the dark premium theme of the site. As
you can see, it looks really, really
good. And this is the light version of
the website. So, both look really really
good. It's just really a matter of
preference as to what you like and what
you like uh your website to look like.
About us looks good, our blog page uh
needs to be configured, our services
look good, and our home page we can see
our services with our custom website.
So, everything is going to be
customizable to your specific site.
Nothing is generic, it's all
customizable for your site. Then we're
going to go to learn more to take a look
at one of our service pages. We see get
our TLDR, which is great for AI search.
We got our titles,
meta description. Everything is well
organized. We got a nice beautiful table
here as well. Everything here is HTML.
If I go to
uh view page source, everything here is
HTML, which essentially makes the
content indexable by Google and actually
rank. Then we get a nice um sort of uh
design block here, how it works, a nice
timeline, ready to get started.
And our service areas with some CTAs.
Below that, we also have our service
areas that we can take a look at. So,
garage door installation in Toronto. And
as you can see, this is not generic
content, right? It's about your company,
it's about the jobs that you've done,
with your license, with your content uh
content uh sorry, with your contact
number, and also with internal links to
go to your CTAs. Beautiful beautiful uh
table here. Everything looks really
really good. Not thin content, it's
actually really really in-depth and deep
content here.
With your callout for your testimonial
that you add in on the back end, FAQ,
again, another beautiful um HTML
elements
with your uh testimonial. So, we have to
tighten up a couple of things
design-wise, but as you can see, this is
not thin content. This is really really
in-depth content that you're getting
back.
As I mentioned before, if we head over
to settings and site profile, this is
where you can actually add your
customizable information to the website,
so we can add more things about your
site uh to ensure that the AI can use
that when it's um creating the web
pages. But again, as you can see here,
you have a lot of pages that you can
simply in one click generate, publish
this to your own custom domain coming
soon, and you can get your website set
up in a couple of minutes rather than,
you know, spending hours setting up your
theme, getting your hosting, then
creating the pages one by one, then
using ChatGPT to research and all that.
This saves so so much time. Again, let's
go ahead and take a look at any one of
these uh service pages. Again, really
really in-depth content here with nice
styled HTML elements, FAQs,
with CTAs as well.
In addition to having pages, you'll also
be able to have an automated blogging uh
sequence. So, we're going to connect
this with Word Rocket so that you can
set up automated blogging based upon
keywords that are actually relevant for
your niche. So, your blogging is also
going to be automated. Your pages are
now automated as well, too, and you can
create it quickly. So, you can have your
site up and running and growing on
autopilot all in one place, including
doing your SEO and your geo audits. So,
it's a really really powerful platform
that we're building here. And of course,
if you guys like it, then you guys let
us know, and we'll continue to build
more and more into it. So, if you want
to get full access to this, just comment
HTML below, and I'll send you guys over
early access you can start playing
around with it, seeing what you can do,
and give us some ideas of things in
which we can do to improve this tool.
Hope that you guys enjoyed today's
video, and I'll see you in the next one.
Take care.